je lui dit j'ai peur de passer ce check
point et lui m'a répondu tu en fais pas
on s'est mis d'accord avec des jld
[Musique]
le 11 septembre 2013 le comité de sûreté
de lafarge note les flux logistiques et
les mouvements de personnel sont
perturbées par les islamistes al nostra
et état islamique
ces derniers exigent que leur soit
versée une taxe afin d'autoriser le
passage des camions et des véhicules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cimentier aurait passé un accord avec
des ch
la preuve ce laisser-passer que nous ont
confié des salariés de lafarge
il porte le tampon du trésorier de
l'état islamique et on peut y lire au
nom d'allah le miséricordieux
les frères moudjahidine sont priés de
laisser passer aux barrages ce véhicule
transportant du ciment de l' usine
lafarge après accord avec l'entreprise
pour le commerce de cette matière tout
mais chauffeur qui transportait du tout
à l'année du pétrole avait un papier
comme celui là ce qui livrait lafarge
oui et les autres entreprises avaient
sans nom il y avait que ceux de lafarge
qui abaisse document
[Musique]
où
il y a eu des erreurs de commises des
erreurs de commises mais encore une fois
dans un cadre qui était un cadre très
difficile et très complexe
les salariés ont vécu des moments
épouvantable épouvantable ce que je peux
dire c'est que en dépit de cette
situation épouvantable
leur sécurité est toujours restée au
coeur des préoccupations et des
priorités de lafarge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aux 25 ouvriers restés sur place la
direction ordonne de ne pas bouger
préparez des matelas de la nourriture de
l'eau et du sucre dans les tunnels
techniques en cas d' attaques de lusine
réfugiez-vous dans les tunnels et
attendait surtout pas de fuite en
voiture en cas d'urgence 18 heures plus
tard l'état islamique pénètre dans l'
usine du cimentier français
une prise considérable pour les
terroristes célébrée par cette vidéo de
propagande
dans l'usiné dévasté les soldats de
dèche parade et se congratulent deux
heures avant l'attaqué des jihadistes le
chef d'equipe allemagne hassan
il est encore à son poste j'ai travaillé
jusqu'à la dernière minute avant
l'arrivée de neige
il n'était plus qu'à deux kilomètres de
l'usiné comment êtes vous parti on a fui
par le côté sud de l' usine
à pied à vélo ou à pied là non en
voiture il y avait ma voiture un
véhicule de l'entreprise et les camions
quand les bombardements se sont
rapprochés on nous a dit qu'ils allaient
attaquer lusine j'ai prévenu tous les
ouvriers et on est parti pour moi les
dirigeants de cette société ne cherchait
qu'à gagner de l'argent il me disait
toujours la sécurité d'abord elle était
où la sécurité ce jour là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons pu consulter un document
exceptionnel
l'agente a dû directeur de la sûreté du
groupe lafarge surprise il indique 12
rendez vous avec un officier de la dgse
entre 2011 et 2014
[Musique]